- You look stunning.
- Oh my gosh.
- I love your dress.
- Thank you.
- Oh my God,
it's like a little cape,
but lower, I like it.
- Thank you.
- It's very cool.
Nice to meet to you.
- I'm very excited so I'm gonna
- Really?
- breathe through
this excitement.
I am such a fan of yours,
so this is everything right now.
- That's so nice.
Thank you.
- So, okay,
my fan girl, I'm gonna try
and put away
- Oh my gosh.
You made me feel good.
- and have a conversation.
- Thank you, I feel awesome now.
Well, tell us the story.
I heard that there's a cool
story of how you got your name.
What is that?
- Yes, the internet likes to say
I was born in a Shell station.
I wasn't, but it is tied in there.
- The internet's dumb
sometimes
- Yes.
My mom was getting her car
worked on at a Shell station
and she went into labor
and the guy who was
helping like keep her calm,
called the ambulance, his name was Chris.
- Yeah.
- And so she wanted to
name me after him.
- No.
- And so she thought, well,
Chris, Shell, Chrishell.
- Oh that's kind of sweet, yeah.
- I wasn't born in a Shell station,
- Yeah.
- but my dad liked to say.
good thing it wasn't a
Texaco, you Chrisexaco.
(audience laughing)
- Which would have been awesome.
So wait, your new
memoir, I love the title.
It's called Under Construction.
So why did you go with that?
- Well, I feel like, you know,
life is a lot of work getting it right
and I feel like you never
really get to that place
where you're like, okay, I figured it out.
It's always gonna be
- Yeah.
- ups and downs
and so I being in real estate,
I feel like it's like
you know, it's a constant
construction project you know?
- Yeah.
- And so that's how it feels
where it's like you
know, it does take work,
but it's worth the work.
- Yeah.
- It is.
I feel like we're always
under construction.
I feel like if you aren't
always under construction
then you've stopped growing.
You've stopped progressing, you know?
- Yeah.
- And I feel like
we wanna do that, right?
- Yeah because I think in
my head before I thought,
oh, those people have it figured out,
if I can just get there.
- If I could, yeah.
When I'm 30
- And now I realize.
- I'll yeah, when I'm 40.
- Yeah, that never happens.
- Yeah, yeah.
That's a depressing notion, but it's true.
It never happens.
You just keep, you just keep
growing, that there it is.
So you talk openly about your exes.
I often write about my situations
like that like in music
and it's very therapeutic for me.
Was it therapeutic for you?
- Your music has gotten
me through many a breakup
so thank you for that.
(audience cheering)
- Me too.
- So thank you.
You've helped all of us.
And yeah, I do think
that this was, you know
just a cathartic situation
because so much is said out there
and sometimes there's
not a lot of context.
- Or clarity, yeah.
- Yeah and coming from
a place of, you know
of a healing place, like
I I am past those things.
I am healed, there's no anger there.
So it's nice to kind of,
you know, give context
and you know, tell a story
that I know a lot of people
have related to that, you
know, these things happen
and whether it, you know,
- Yeah.
- and sometimes they're not all great
and you know, Instagram and stuff
you only see the good stuff.
- The filtered versions.
- So it's nice to kind of,
yeah, you know, get into the real stuff
and explain how you go from there
to you know
- Yeah.
- getting back to the good part.
- Yeah, no, absolutely.
It's nice too because everybody is working
through those same, we're
all under construction
so it's very relatable,
but I did hear this was pretty good.
So you sold your wedding ring
to help pay for your new house.
Was that therapeutic
'cause.
- Well.
- I love that
- You know, Kelly.
- That's funny.
- I will say, when sometimes
life gives you lemons,
sometimes you gotta add a little vodka.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So yeah.
- That's amazing.
- I was trying to, you know,
make the best out of a situation so.
- Yeah.
- What are you supposed to, do?
Keep wearing it, like,
you know, I guess, yeah.
Yeah, I think that's amazing.
- Yeah.
- You did something good with the money.
So speaking of houses,
what can you tell us about the
new season of Selling Sunset?
- Okay, well, you guys are
gonna have a lot of drama
coming your way, which I know people love,
that always gives me so much
anxiety, but there's a lot.
(audience laughing)
- Is that in your book.
I love that, that's amazing.
- Yeah, there's some
BTS about that in there,
but it's also, you know
the homes are amazing.
The biggest deals we've ever done.
The celebrities that
we we get to work with
that agreed to be on the show
'cause now they're not
so scared to be on it,
you know?
- Yeah.
- And you know, obviously
there's some personal aspects for me
- Yeah.
- that are gonna be on there
that, you know, it's probably
gonna be a little hard
to relive some of these things
'cause it goes into the
relationship I was in at the time.
- Yeah.
- But I think
that it's also therapeutic, you know
because that was a piece
of my life that I lived
and you know, I can't act
like it didn't happen,
I definitely can't now
'cause you guys are
gonna see the new season.
(audience laughing)
- So.
- I feel like, you know, I'm doing my best
and this is my life and you know,
- Yeah.
- you're gonna see the good
and the bad and once you embrace it.
now I'm having the best
time I've ever had.
- That's so awesome.
We only get one life, might as well,
right?
- Yes.
- Well we have the exclusive premiere
of Selling Sunset season five trailer,
so let's see that
- I'm in love, babe.
- I feel like things
are going really well.
- It is risky when you're in an office
and you're obviously dating your boss.
- I was wondering why I
wasn't getting listings
and I was like, oh yeah,
it's cause I'm not my boss.
- Hi.
- Hi, Chelsea Lazkani.
- Chelsea, Christine,
nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
I always get what I want.
- Every time she's around
the energy changes.
- If she's losing clients,
we have to take that into consideration
when we're looking at who's
gonna stay at the brokerage.
Is this like the end for her?
(audience cheering)
- All right, so that was
Chrishell in Selling Sunset,
y'all you can see it soon on Netflix
and pick up her new book,
it is called Under
Construction and it's out now,
you gotta check it out.